- On this episode,
I try to meet you on Saturday,
and I force you to leave a comment
or I'm gonna quit.
(hip-hop music)
You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody!
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this episode five zero, 50,
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
So I'm super pumped about episode 50.
A lot of talk about what are we gonna do,
what special thing,
and you know, once again,
my insanity procrastination
have created me to go this way,
which is, we're not gonna
do anything special.
We're just gonna keep
grinding and hustling,
which is the PR answer to
just didn't get to it.
We'll do something
awesome for episode 100.
Before I get into the questions,
I want to say that I miss the show.
I feel like what was
Tuesday the last time.
This might have been the longest I've gone
since we started the show without it.
I know it's a lot of you
who said that you missed it,
which makes me feel nice.
And I wanna also say to the VaynerNation,
and especially the wine Vayniacs,
I don't know what kind
of graphics you do here,
I'm gonna whisper for the podcast,
it's a very substantially
exciting day for me
on Saturday.
This upcoming Saturday.
I don't know what I'm
doing here for you, DRock.
Staphon, do something.
But Saturday, I will
be at the Wine Library,
back to the future, to my roots,
working the floor, helping
you pick holiday wines
and spirits and beers and all that
from 11pm to 6pm,
Springfield, New Jersey.
I'm excited.
I hope a bunch of you roadtrip.
Get in the comments and like,
team up, Uber up, rent the bus.
I'm really looking forward.
Here's your chance to
come take a little selfie,
pick some awesome wine and spirits.
I'm really excited for this.
I think anybody who's been
paying attention to me
knows that I've caught the wine bug again.
I'm really looking forward to it.
So please.
Oh, can we do an RSVP?
Let's do a little RSVP on Facebook.
Let's link that there.
Let's make sure we do
that right after this
and set up an RSVP.
RSVP up,
bring your friends, send your friends.
I really want it to be chaos.
I want the Wine Library staff to be like,
Whoa, what are you up to?
This VaynerNation is insanity.
So, stop by on Saturday.
Let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Mike asks,
"If you don't care about the competition,
"what do you say when a client asks you
"about a competitor,
"and why you're better?"
- Mike, this is a tremendous question.
I've dealt with this in
the past on VaynerMedia's
road to success,
and I still do all the time.
People bring up
competitors and I answer
in a very condescending way towards them.
I dislike my competitors
in the context of the game.
Some of them are friends
outside of the game
and I can share a beer,
I can separate it.
I can share a beer at a game
or be cordial in public,
but deep down, I'm not
a fan of my competitors.
I dislike them.
And when people bring them up,
I tend to tear them down
as quickly as possible
or remind them why I'm better
and come up with historical things like,
you know, in the agency world for example,
I say,
Oh you mean those people
that try to win awards
in a world where I grew
up trying to sell stuff?
Anything that I think
will make that person realize
that it is a worthwhile
venture to go with us
and why it's a
wasteful conversation to
care about somebody else.
That is something I will do.
Now look,
I'm a good salesman, a good talker,
I've got great tact,
I have enormous empathy and great feel.
I can read the room.
So I know where to navigate in real time,
which is why I sell and win so often.
You may not have that skill set
and you may come across as
you know, inappropriate, awkward,
you know,
inappropriate.
And so, you know,
for all of you on this side over here
who can read the room,
can move quickly on your feet,
can rock and roll that way,
just punch your competitor in the face.
Over here,
not as smooth,
you're not quite as sure,
you don't understand
where they want to go,
you've got to go with a different route.
I don't know what that route is,
but it's (bleep).
- [Voiceover] Dan asks,
"White lies.
"Do you believe the hype?
"It seems you can't win in business
"without bending the truth."
- Dan, this is a really intense question.
I want you to show India right now,
because I'm giving her props
for navigating the
questions and finding stuff.
This question is one
that I'm really struggling to figure out
what the right answer is,
which leads to the answer which is,
appropriate embellishment
feels appropriate at times to me,
but I'm scared to say that out loud.
If you feel like you're growing into it
within weeks
or maybe maximum a couple of months,
I think it's okay. Right?
Like, I feel comfortable
saying VaynerMedia's
a 450-person agency right now
even though we're 417,
but we have 59 job openings,
and I expect this to be 450
by the time the far majority of people
watch this episode or listen to it, right?
So,
I guess that's where I'm willing to go.
I'm not willing to say we're 7,000.
I'm not willing to say we're 1,000.
I think fake it 'til you make it
is a very scary line
that I think most people struggle with,
but you know,
we live in a transparent world.
Like,
the reason I even say this answer
is 'cause I'm always trying to correct
myself,
'cause I'm scared to, like,
get called out for,
you're losing all your credibility
by getting called out on something.
So, it's a very fine line.
I think the intent matters.
For me, I'm just going in speed,
rounding out numbers, I'm going fast.
Not trying to trick you to think
we're bigger than we are.
So I would answer you a couple things.
One,
white lies that become truths
within a very quick or
short period of time
feel a little more comfortable,
and the intent of the white lie.
If you feel like,
if you feel like you're not
trying to do the wrong thing,
that you're gonna be able to
deliver for the other person,
you just wanna tip them over
in their own,
you know it's so funny, with my clients,
I think they get so much more benefit
working with us than the alternative
that I'm like,
I feel like I'm helping them along.
I feel like it's in their
best interest, not mine.
Of course there's a secondary
best interest of mine,
and it's funny,
I tend to not,
you all right?
What's that?
(laughs)
Are we meeting?
- Yes.
- I'm running just a few minutes late.
Do you wanna say hi to the VaynerNation?
- Hi guys! I'm Claire.
- Um,
you know, I think that it's all about
like every other answer which is,
it needs to have the right intent
and it needs to be appropriate.
So, that's what I got.
- Hey Gary.
Miles Keever with HappyHumanoids.com.
In episode 49, you were asked a question
about high-end wine
business and was it a hoax.
Now, I thought your answer
was brilliant and profound.
So profound that I checked
out and I began observing
your staff members behind you.
Lots of them are standing without chairs,
and when you asked Lou to go get DeMayo,
somebody snatched his
chair out of the way.
Do you have a set up in your community?
A way to keep the competitive edge going
by not having enough chairs?
- First of all, who's Lou?
- [Man] Little Lou!
- Oh, Little Lou!
You're right.
I literally think of him as Little Lou.
This question
is so perfect for episode 50
because I'm so
devastated that I'm not
limiting chairs on purpose
to create a competitive culture,
so the answer is no.
I haven't created that on purpose,
but yes, yes, yes, do I wish I did.
I love the thesis behind it.
I think it's a phenomenal observation.
I desperately wish it was true.
And I will say this,
I don't have any hardcore tactics
to create competitiveness.
And as a matter of fact,
one of the biggest things that I really
value is that a lot of the senior people
that have been coming into VaynerMedia
say this is the first
agency they'd ever worked in
that people are competitive
because they wanna do great work
but not at the cost of their
other employees around them
which means we're building real culture.
It excites me
and it's something that I strive for.
But I do think everything
stems from the top,
and I don't know how I do it,
but boy, do I know I breed
competitiveness here,
because I'm competitive as (bleep).
- [Voiceover] Terri says,
"I saw a discussion via Linkedin
"about Klout scores on a resume.
"What are your thoughts on them?"
- Terri, this is a question.
I'm glad everybody's gonna
get to hear my answer
and this has nothing
to do with my feelings
towards Klout itself.
These kind of scoring systems
that try to prove your social
equity in the marketplace
are not things I'm a big fan of.
They're super gameable.
Let me say something really interesting.
Pssst.
Psst.
A lot of you have hit me up on Twitter
because if I replied to you,
you knew that your
Klout score would go up.
Now this is more of a 2012 move
and has become something
less and less of you have done,
but you know, if you look
yourself in the mirror right now,
you knew that you were trying to game me
for more Klout scores
and I was thrilled to give it to you
because I know how
little it actually meant.
And because I love you
and that you even know who I am
and I wanted to give you some love,
but people who literally tweeted out,
like oh, got some Klout juice,
because they engaged
with me on that platform.
Look, my answer is very simple,
and very, very hardcore,
which is, I never signed
up for a Klout account
while I had one of the
bigger scores up there,
so that's kind of called
eating your own dog food, right?
Taking your own medicine.
I believe in it so little
that I didn't even want to acknowledge it
by signing up,
even though it was probably
in my best interest
both personally, and too, professionally
to just understand how it worked.
So again, has nothing to do with Klout.
I feel the same way about
a million other things.
It is not something,
the big data version of your worth
is not something I'm super pumped about.
You obviously might have seen
my own last Medium article about empathy
and the hidden truths of people.
I'm so much more into the
grey, intuitive and EQ of people
than I am the black and white,
which is what Klout is.
It's just raw data dumped
and figured, if like,
it's high school math.
And when I mean high school math,
go deeper with me,
it's the math of how high school works.
The popular girl decides that
she likes Steve and
she goes out with him.
Well, his Klout score
went through the roof
because he was in the band before that.
You know, so it's that kind of thing.
- [Voiceover] Dan wants to know
"Are there any common mistakes you repeat
"over and over again?
"Either way, any tips
for overcoming them?"
- Dan,
I think I repeat all my
mistakes over and over again.
First of all, my thesis on life
is scaling the unscalable,
which is one big mistake in itself.
We just had a meeting with the whole crew
about all the mistakes I'm making,
bottle of,
bottom of the funnel things.
So you know, like,
you know,
I'm a big believer of betting
on strengths, not weaknesses,
you know, you try to get better
as you go through the process
and go along.
I don't know if I'm the
right person to answer this.
I repeat a lot of mistakes.
I continue to always,
I have good moments for a year or two
or a month of two of
not trying to bite off
more than I can chew,
but then I get right into it.
For all the process and scalability,
I continue to create things
that allow me to be the bottleneck,
though I think this crew and I
are doing a good job of hacking away
and we have an ambition
for '15 to be better at it
in my limited time world.
You know, I...
But, really, these are
all hard questions for me
because I really
struggle to think about what I'm bad at
because I spend all my time
thinking about what I'm great at
and those are a lot of things.
And that's where I put my energy and time
and that's why I think
I get the permission
and the luxury
and the awesome feeling
of having so many of you
watch this show,
betting on strengths is
the grossly underestimated
execution of our time.
And that's what I do and I do it well,
and so I answered it out of
being a cordial human being,
but the truth is,
I don't give a rat's
ass about my weaknesses.
I surely don't know how to fix them
because
I don't focus on them much.
Once in a while,
and that's that.
And so in final thoughts,
I want to thank so many of you
for watching the first 50
episodes of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I don't know how many more of these
I have in tank,
but it's been an amazing ride.
Don't worry, DRock.
I just mentioned we're
gonna do episode 100.
Just trying to scare the Nation.
Uh...
Question of the day.
And I expect a lot of lurkers to come out
because if you want me to get to that 100,
I need the feedback loop.
It's the only thing that keeps me going.
As Wine Library TV's
feedback loop waned, I waned.
So you like it?
Not asking you for money.
I'm asking you for comments, god dammit.
And so,
in the Comments section,
get out of the podcast people,
pull your (bleep) car over
and open up your phone
and leave a comment.
I don't care how you do it.
Here are the two basic questions.
Number one,
are you coming on Saturday?
Simple! Yes, no.
Are you making the schlep?
And by the way,
PA, Connecticut, and New York,
I expect things from you.
Jersey, it's a forgone conclusion.
If somebody flies in, forget it.
And number two,
I need your recap
of the first 50 episodes
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
And to make it simple, 'cause
some of you struggle with this
which will give me less comments,
give me the best thing
it's brought to you.
The best!
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
On this episode,
I explain why I got the wine (mumbling).
(laughter)
Oh, crap! Wait!
Subscribe!
(makes bursting noises)
I need subscriptions
because I can't push this
many right hooks in social.
So subscribe!